let's let's talk about ex-con - yeah so
it's been over three years since Firaxis
relaunched XCOM so it's probably about
time we got a sequel Mike you reviewed
ex-con - for GameSpot you gave it a 9
out of 10 so I guess that answers the
first question this is better than Tara
from the deep and in terms of a seat
yeah what is it about ex come to that it
makes it so good it seems like it's
reinvented quite a lot of what the first
game did yeah it's good as a sequel just
it's not just this big expansion like
enemy within is it's very much its own
game you know what you're getting into
if you played enemy unknown enemy within
but it does revamp some of the core
mechanics of that made enemy unknown
kind of held it back from being great
hmm it's also just there are so many
different layers to it I think I've
played according to Steam I played about
66 hours at this point but that's not
counting another account I had for the
review and I'm still today I'm finding
out new things I'm going over to talk to
Chris waters and like people playing it
and I'm saying did you do this yet and
it's things I didn't see during the
review process but it's they revamped so
much of how the formula works all for
the better and it's it's for people that
have played at me unknown enemy within
and for people new to it people are
asking can I jump in it - like yeah
absolutely
go for it so we've talked about this a
little bit but just again a brief sort
of synopsis of what exactly is changed
in terms of your technical tactical
influence on the map like your the roles
have been flipped right you're the one
who's kind of like the aggressor this
time yeah it picks up in terms of
narrative in the gameplay it picks up as
if it's 20 years after enemy Unknown and
the aliens won when you were trying to
defend earth it's really it's it's it
kind of ties in the gameplay really well
like from the strategy the overarching
world map layer you're not you're like
this mobile base called the Avenger and
you're doing the same thing clearing out
the lower levels like you were and
building new facilities that's literally
like a floating yeah base ship it's like
The Avengers helibase right forget yeah
and you're you're moving that around the
map and instead of kind of setting up
satellite uplinks to defend earth you're
connecting with other rebel cells
across the world because you're part of
the resistance fighting it's the advent
this alien regime and but unate acting
from a tactical standpoint now vast
majority of missions you drop in under
concealment so there's this fog
as long as you don't cross like a vision
cone or these vision tiles from enemies
you won't alert them and you can kind of
set up these ambushes and take your time
so cool and that does that lets you saw
these ambushes where you can kill us a
group of enemies right away and then
your you're out of concealment but also
it kind of negates that whole thing in
enemy Unknown a lot of people got tired
of the game after a while yes at the
beginning of each mission you're doing
overwatch walking frog oh yeah just
every single level it was the same thing
right so now you can - without like
worrying that they're just gonna spring
out every well you not entirely but you
you you don't worry about them kind of
doing that as much now it's still makes
you cautious in a really good way but
now it's more thoughtful about it so
that's an interesting new tactical
element that's the first question that I
want to high school a lot of people in
the chod are asking as well and also
echoes a lot of what the conversations
have happened with in the office about
this game is XCOM - harder yeah you
played as well yeah awesome I agree I
feel like I don't know this is a I don't
know if you guys have noticed this but
when you're playing do you feel like
you're your fighters are more prone to
like panic or like freaked out I
definitely thought that at this at least
when they were rookies yeah but that was
happening a lot it happens way more
often especially in the beginning and I
feel like that sort of made my first
couple hours a lot harder because
everyone was just freaking out all the
time like don't sign up to a militia
group what an alien can't got it yeah
just like that he's like the character
from Saving Private Ryan who doesn't do
anything until the rest of the
reinforcements have come yeah no
definitely it's it's also kind of kind
of mirrors how you feel like if you're
losing one guy and then there's a poison
grenade covering three other ones you're
starting to panic and then all of a
sudden want your rookies pan actually
alright well I can't really blame them
entirely but they also it's awesome when
you get people to like lieutenant and
Captain and like they're impervious to
almost everything alien tech toys will
try to mind-control them right now [ __ ]
off em I'm fine so have either of you
restarted your campaigns well I'm
guessing you have like I like so have
you had to restart your campaigns at all
do you sort of like taken away it it
okay chipping away at it that's I feel
like it what cuz like I feel like that
set up into iron once he like start
playing a little more is that he ended
up having to restart a couple of times
did you have that experience as well
yeah I
review process I played on Ironman I
just enjoy a game that much more well
yeah which people who don't know it's
it's it progressively saves after every
single thing you do and the only way to
get out is to save and exit so you
cannot reload a previous say you get to
deal with your consequences and that's
not me like humble bragging at all its I
just enjoy the game much more I've
failed quite a few times over the I've
completed two campaigns one was on a
veteran one they were both on veteran
which is the default difficulty yeah
that's another thing they bumped all the
difficulties up like one level yeah it
says the description next to veteran
says if you're an experienced ex-con
player play this I I would recommend
even if you played a lot of the first
two or the first one the expansion start
on rookie there are a lot of new layers
to get used to the tutorial does a good
job explaining there's so many things
out ambushes and the strategy layer and
what text to research that you don't
learn until about like 20 hours anderson
is there a lot of the base building ii
like management stuff is that as much
because like that was the big thing they
stripped out of i feel like the big
difference between enemy unknown or UFO
defense i guess was over here right
enemy enemy what was the original denial
UFO defense here and anyway known as was
in europe the main difference between
that one and the reboot was that a lot
of the base building stuff had been
stripped out like back off pretty
nitty-gritty has i've been layered back
in again or is it is it still kind of
similar to 2x on 3 by year's bike it's
it's it's still very much like enemy
Unknown it's it's there it's a big deal
what facilities you build cuz you have a
limited space and you also you're
clearing out alley and debris from the
avenger from the bottom floors so funny
yes I'm claiming your house so you can
put furniture in it yeah exactly
furniture that helps you research like
mind control yes and you get supplies
from that so it's a huge deal but you
also have like you start learning which
facilities to build and you start
learning where to put your engineers so
they buff certain facilities and how
about certain things faster you get
scientists which are still really
important but it's not as dense as the
older games were it's still very much
like enemy Unknown but it is the added
mechanic of you know it's a mobile base
and you actually takes time to travel
obviously from place to place so if
you're traveling far you could land and
then there will be a mission waiting for
you that's happened to me all the time
especially on the higher difficulties
and when you're right like on your last
string
you're like I was in East Africa and I
had to fly that western US like God
there's gonna be something horrible
waiting and there was a there was a they
had attacked some like New York or
something so you have to really manage
your time like so much this game is
managing time now and it is stressful
but that's part of what makes it fun
because you're kind of thinking on that
layer too not just resources and
soldiers but you're also managing how
much time do I have left and make this
decision it's awesome I've reached
there's a bunch of questions you're
coming in via twitch also reach out to
folks on Twitter beforehand and for some
questions for you Mike the reviewer but
actually want to ask Alexa this one
because I think you might be able to
speak to this Brenda's asking and when
do you think they're gonna buckle and
pay some port has to put it on
PlayStation 4 and iOS do you think this
is a game because it's only on PC at the
moment do you think like any realities
of sort of game develop in nowadays that
eventually they will bring this out on
Xbox one Playstation 4 or maybe do the
iOS thing which was very successful for
them I believe I have a feeling based on
the way that the game controls and based
on like resources and like how many
other companies are going to like oh
like paying a third party to like ported
all to a console and so many games are
now ported on everything these days I
feel like based on the performance of
enemy Unknown an enemy within they would
probably port it to mobile first before
I want it to ps4 XL very well I didn't
realize I was listening to a couple of
podcasts last week and they're talking
about how apparently like the iOS one
did like you rightly said but lebar need
the console ones the Xbox 360 version
did not sell yeah are you gonna be great
and if the audience is not there then I
can definitely see them being like ok
like we're not gonna bring it to these
additional consoles yeah there's people
that probably won't play it like I don't
have a gaming PC yet
sorry for another time so I've been like
playing here and playing on my
boyfriend's PC but the joys of moving I
know right now first thing I did I took
a while there yeah yeah but I don't
think I don't think they would I don't
think they'll do it anytime soon or if
at all but mobile probably that's a find
out my question for you then a bit more
specific about the Iron Man stuff at
Christian Marsh masking is it bug free
enough to do Iron Man off the bat once
we were saying there's some stability
issues with it yeah did you come across
those and yeah my only complaints with
it aside from things that carried over
from enemy
where the enemy kind of ignores the
rules of the game and it does get
frustrating but um yeah I I would
recommend I'd like the game a lot more
on Iron Man and I think even with the
bugs the bugs I experienced were not
actually hindering me it was just more
like frustration like when they would
sprint and I would go into overwatch and
fire with them we kind of freeze for a
few seconds it was as if the game was
trying to figure out what to show first
and when we know it it was it was more
that and not as much things that were
actually impeding my progress there were
a couple times when somehow this my
sight line didn't make sense I was 100%
sure I should have flanked something and
they give me like the yellow critical
indicator of their face right but it was
still like a ten percent chance to hit
and that was my last move that turn
because it was one of those objective
missions but I would say just if you
prefer Iron Man and historically just go
for it just play in your gonna fail
probably and that's not me insulting you
that's just this game is hard and that's
as part of the play this game right yeah
you learn a lot like that you don't
always finish the first time oh yeah I
think it took me on the default
difficulty with Iron Man I think it was
the third campaign I finally got toward
the enemies but but even then it was and
then each one was like 12 to 18 hours -
so you could take it a while but there's
a whole overarching thing that kind of
makes you speed up there's this it's
called the Avatar project I won't spoil
what it is because there is kind of more
of a narrative in this game but it's
yeah this read progress bar keeps
ticking one box at a time and if it
fills up you have I think it's twenty
days before you just lose and you have
to get to an Advent facility which it
could be in like Chile and you're up in
eastern like you're in Asia yeah and so
you have to first establish an uplink in
Western Europe and then go to Chile
which in that like that would probably
take you like 15 days it's like it's
like beating this bar back right it's
like it's there are very few times in
this game where you're gonna feel
comfortable at all if you're not losing
a soldier like you're losing contact
with a region they're kind of you have
an Advent facility that you have to go
destroy yet you two regions away and
it's dynamic is alright this is it's not
like the levels are a dynamic generators
or randomly or whatever yeah they're
procedural in terms of maps and the
objectives they're probably about 10 to
12 rotating objectives aside from the
main story beats you still have to build
the certain facility
to progress in the campaign and do
autopsies on these certain kinds of
enemies in order to unlock these this
thing you have to do to capture an enemy
and but outside of that there's certain
missions we have to destroy these alien
relays there's certain ones where you
have to extract someone to this evac
point before a certain time there's a
time around a lot of these which I know
a lot of people didn't like but I think
yeah they like them from the design
standpoint they bring you out of your
comfort zone if such a thing exists to
begin with in this game yeah
and the last question I'm gonna throw
out there because it's it's been a
critical times who AM aqua in the twitch
chat and how are these small cameras
slash map selection glitches and X come
to compared to enemy Unknown I got
something people are pretty familiar wet
especially we would like when you're
coming into the animations and was that
what you're talking about with the yeah
thing those were the main things so they
did provide reviewers with like a list
of known bugs that would be fixed by
launch which is what Friday Thursday
night midnight are they are they fixed
my launch I don't know yet I'm gonna
check it out Thursday night but again I
wasn't I still it wasn't enough I
mentioned them but it wasn't enough to
hinder the overall experience I had but
yeah they are a lot of times you'll be
it'll go into overwatch and it'll show
like over the shoulder from your soldier
even if you turn the action cam off
it'll still show the enemy like frozen
there forever eyes and at 15 seconds so
long especially especially in this game
where you know you have a certain
percentage to hit so you're like oh my
god just 45 gonna screw me over is this
oh my god so the whole time they're
frozen you're just I'm just like it's
like Paul's four-eyed break yeah we'll
see after these messages
just get nauseous and have a headache
and then finally you miss like okay make
sense sounds like a pretty great game
though yeah contrary to like what I'm
talking about in those kind of
situations it really is it's awesome
it's you think on so many different
levels from the strategy layer to the
tactical air you just start getting
attached to individual soldiers
especially because it's kind of devious
they let you really customize your
soldiers oh yeah but as you're doing
you're like this person's gonna die it's
what's the point
I love the customization in this game it
goes pretty deep I made armor for all my
people that has a it's actually a heart
pattern and so the hearts were
alternating like black and black and
white yeah that's really cool and you
can put them in like a pool of players
now so even if your game ends you don't
have to like remake them or anything it
just kind of pulls the marriage yeah I
gave you like Irish colors in your armor
and then
what was my nickname oh one one campaign
you forgot what you did but they ended
up giving you a nickname all day
it's like Danny all day or twice and
then he died and yeah how did he go oh I
think I showed you the capture footage
we had you fell down literally in this
bed of roses I swear
Wow this Viper one of the new enemy
types wrapped you up and I couldn't
Chris waters missed the shot rocked me
over better yeah [ __ ] Guns and Roses
snake the Viper yeah yeah the Vipers
they they're what thin men they're thin
men but they don't need the disguise
anymore so they're just their true form
of these my person and they they coil
you up and if no one else attacks them
or hits them yeah then you'll just keep
doing damage and so you were just stuck
inside it and Chris waters mr. crucial
shot if he was watching out it still
hurts Chris but yeah you died but then i
zoomed in and kind of rotated slowly
yeah saw you you're cradling your
machine gun all day baby Jesus Christ
like right thank you so much for coming
in and telling us asking questions about
your review x-ray career I think you've
grown into giving us your opinion on
this game as well really appreciate it
folks let us know what you think are you
excited about XCOM - it sounds like a
lot of people arrange the next column
we're interested months ago and they're
just gonna go ahead and buy it but if
you're somebody who perhaps wasn't
thinking about getting it and the
reviews have changed your mind let us
know as well in the comment box below